while safety advocates were on the
lookout for a driver speeding through
crosswalks this morning a woman narrowly
escaped a semi going through the
crosswalk as hector mejia reports this
is a good reminder as the days get
shorter for both drivers and pedestrians
to pay attention
by nevada law drivers are required to
stop for pedestrians where two streets
intersect or there's a marked location
this is ccsd police officer keith habig
dressed as a fairy he's crossing boulder
highway near twain i should most
definitely catch their eye in something
this bright if someone dressed in a
bright yellow fairy costume if people
don't stop for him
what chance does the average pedestrian
get jacqueline suarez works nearby and
says she sees the safety issues with
pedestrians and drivers almost daily it
seems like people are just daredevils
and just throwing themselves in the
middle of the street and nobody is
stopping she saw a close call this
morning even while police were out this
lady was just crossing the street in the
semi
i mean
it takes a while for them to stop and he
almost hit her he swerved i try to teach
the kids a lot of times when you're
getting into a crosswalk make eye
contact with the drivers make sure that
they're going to stop don't just keep
your head down and walk across and
assume that everybody is going to stop
hector mejia reporting live local now